il faut faire quelques différences
dedans justement les gens qui
aujourd'hui découvre que tariq ramadan
était un prédicateur non pas musulman
mais islamiste et qu'il avait comme
idéologie l'idéologie de ce qu'on
appelle l'islam politique des frères
musulmans
pas seulement parce qu'il est le petit
fils de des fonds du fondateur des
frères musulmans mais parce que c'est un
des principaux orateurs et un
prédicateur quand vous disiez dans
l'ensemble des des groupes d soient des
lieux de culte soient des lieux
culturels comme on dit proche des frères
musulmans avec cette nuance très
particulière par rapport à son frère
notamment hani ramadan qui lui le fait
ouvertement qui est ouvertement qui dit
ouvertement les choses tariq ramadan a
toujours eu ce qu'on a appelé s'est
illustré dans sur le figaro le double
discours c'est à dire un discours à
destination des médias des des
occidentaux enfin en général et un
discours à destination des populations
musulmanes auprès desquels il exerçait
sa sa prédication ç'avait été mis en
avant par certaines personnes qui dans
la démonstration de cette dualité et de
la réalité de l'idéologie de ramadhan le
font depuis longtemps on peut penser
notamment parce qu'elle a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de mal et elle en a beaucoup
souffert publiquement à caroline fourest
qui est le ce courage
il ya très longtemps de le faire
d'autres aussi bon ça fait partie d'un
combat contre l'islamisme et l'islam
politique en particulier qu'on peut
mener depuis des années